The one who is the true light, who gives light
to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
But who was this light?
He was and is God with us?
God with us.
Have you ever just stopped to think about
that phrase for a second?
Like that phrase comes from the word in the Bible, Emmanuel,
which you can spell with an E or an I.
It's various ways, but that that's what it means.
It means God with us.
It's a theological reality that we celebrate, especially
around Christmas time.
But But have you really thought about it?
Like have you really stopped
and dwelled on that reality, thought deeply about
God, the God of Gods, the Lord of the universe
with like among next to rubbing shoulders, with right
with us,
sinful humans like you
and me, God with
us, what we're gonna look at over the next couple
Sundays is that phrase deeply.
We're gonna dive into what that really means, God with us.
And so take your copy of God's word, turn with me
to the gospel of John in the New Testament.
You'll find the gospels, Matthew, mark, Luke,
and then John about three fourths of the way through.
If you're unfamiliar with the Bible, that's fine.
Just open it up, find it that way.
Gospel of John over the next three weeks, like I said,
we're gonna walk verse by verse through the first 18 verses
of John chapter one.
And we're gonna see profound truths about who God is,
but also how that then relates to our lives.
What that means for us as we live daily.
And these first five verses will be more than enough
for us today as we look at how God with us brings
life in more ways than one.
Look at John one, one through five.
In the beginning was the word and the word was with God.
And the word was God. He was in the beginning with God.
All things were made through him.
Without Him was not anything made that was made
in him was life.
And the life was the light of men.
The light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it.
God, this is your word
and we need you to open our eyes to see
and understand what it means and what it means for us.
Holy Spirit, teach us today.
May it be your words, not mine.
And we can do nothing apart from you, Jesus.
And so we ask you to bear good fruit
through this for your glory.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So you can see in those five
verses, there's a whole lot there, right?
Like we could spend weeks on just the first verse,
but before we dig into it, we need to know why John
the apostle disciple of Jesus, why did he even write this?
What was going on that precipitated him
to write down these few verses?
Well, what we know was at the time,
he was addressing a common heresy or a falsehood about God.
Sadly, one that has persisted even for the last 2000 years.
'cause what they were, what they were saying at the time,
people were saying at the time that that Jesus
was a good person, but he was not the son of God.
Or they were saying that Jesus was unusual, yes,
but he wasn't divine.
That he had clearly a measure of the spirit
of God resting on him,
but he was just a human like you and me.
Again, that's not just back then.
You might have heard those very things this week.
Anytime someone says that Jesus was merely a good teacher,
or anytime someone says that he sinned as a human,
which sadly a large percentage of people
who call themselves Christians believe Jesus sinned.
Right? Anytime you hear those kinds of things,
that's the same idea
that John was addressing 2000 years ago.
That's why he started the way he did in verse one.
What were the critical first words that he started with?
He says in the beginning, right?
That's the first three words of verse one in the beginning.
John didn't start with the birth of Jesus like Luke does,
Like Matthew does.
John didn't uh, start with the baptism
of Jesus like Mark did.
No, John started with the initiation of time itself.
He goes way back in the beginning.
Now that
that phrase might ring a bell in our minds, right?
Kids, you've heard that before. Somewhere.
It sounds like the start of another book
of the Bible might be familiar with namely Genesis,
the first book of the Bible, the creation account.
Here's how it starts.
Verse one in the beginning, God created.
Now, let's even shorten that for a second.
In the beginning, God, what that means
is that God was already there when time
as we know it started.
He had no beginning
'cause he was there in the beginning, right?
You understand that John one says the same thing about
the word in the beginning
was the word, verse two.
He was in the beginning, right? So he already existed.
Okay, so then who is this word? That's the next question.
We need to know who that word actually is.
It's capitalized in your Bible, right?
Clearly something unique going on here, but who is it?
Well, we already know from this passage, the word is God,
but we have to tie it with the rest of the chapter
to understand who it is, right?
To fully understand what this is happening, what's
who this word is.
So I'm gonna jump ahead just a second.
We'll get there in a couple weeks,
but look down at verse 14 here in chapter one,
look at verse 14, see what it says.
And the word became flesh and dwelled among us.
And we have seen His glory.
Glory as of the only son from the Father full
of grace and truth.
So with verse one, we know the word is God,
yet this word took on flesh and dwelt among us.
Plus John writes, this act shows the words glory,
which is the same glory as of the only son from the Father.
So you follow the logic here, right?
The word shows the glory of the Son from the Father.
So John is teaching us here the word in verse one is the
God, the Son, the son of God.
That's who it is.
The second person of the trinity who took on flesh,
which then we now know as Jesus.
Now I know this is hard to understand.
We're going back to what we did in January with the Trinity
and the incarnation, all this stuff, yes,
it's hard to understand.
But what that should do, anytime you run into something
that's hard to understand about God,
what it should do is it should increase our awe
and wonder at this Emmanuel idea, God with us,
he came, God, this God came to be with us.
Wow. So
what do we learn about this?
God, just from these first few verses,
well first we've already talked about this.
We learn that God the Son is eternal.
The word God the Son, right? Interchangeable, he's eternal.
Remember he was in the beginning, he was already there.
He was not created at any point. He pre-existed.
He existed from before time began.
It's the same phrase as Genesis one.
In the beginning, God, in the beginning was the word
again, this is stunning
because this God who exists outside of time,
he entered into time to be with us, to be Emmanuel.
'cause he, he was, he was there before time began.
Like that's hard to understand. But that means the God
who is outside of time chose a date to be born.
I love how HB Charles said it. Many babies have become king.
Only once has a king become a baby.
He is eternal. But there's something
even more profound here.
The second phrase of verse one, this word God the Son,
he is not God the Father.
What are we learning from John? One?
We're seeing God is eternal God, the Son is eternal God.
The Son is also not God the Father
because what does it say the word was with God?
Now that phrase could
and has led some people to say, well there's
that means there's more than one God in,
in fact, there are some so-called Christian heresies
that say that very thing.
Even offering up the fact that you could be one
of those gods, which by the way,
that's a great growth strategy.
Like who wouldn't want that, right?
Yeah, I wanna rule my own world. Of course you would.
But what is this verse actually saying?
Is it if it's not saying there's more than one God?
'cause we know God is one. How is this actually saying
something that makes sense?
Well, John was referencing what we now know as the Trinity,
that God is three in one, one in three, the Trinity.
Now this is one of the most difficult concepts in all
of Christianity to at least grasp a little bit.
We won't fully understand it,
but there's three persons, one, God, father,
son, holy Spirit.
They're not the same,
but they're all God, three persons.
One essence, one being that again, it's difficult
to understand now, we'll we'll get to their oneness
and equality in a second,
but this phrase here, the word was with
God is emphasizing the distinction
between the son and the father.
That there's not the same there. There's a distinctness.
That word with that implies closeness, implies intimacy.
Like you're facing each other.
The persons then of the Father
and the Son are distinguishable but are not separable.
They're distinguishable, but they're inseparable.
And this is not something we're making up, okay?
We're not looking back
theologically trying to create something.
Jesus said this John 17, verse five, as he's praying Now,
father glorify me in your own presence with the glory
that I had with you before the world existed.
So Jesus himself is saying, distinct Father,
but I had glory with you.
That with idea, same kind of thing, inseparable ness.
So the Son is not the Father
since the word was forever with God, meaning
with the Father.
Yet at the same time,
the very next phrase in verse one of John one says this
and the word was God.
Okay? So the son is not the Father, which
we kind of get that right.
We gotta handle that carefully theologically, but,
but we kind of get that right.
The son's not the father, but the son is God just as much
as the Father is God.
The way theologians say it is that God, the Son, is co-equal
with God, the Father
and God, the Spirit, the Son is
co-equal with the Father.
So distinct persons,
but one being right?
Like I get we under, we can't understand that.
It's mind blowing to think about how this works.
And it's really hard for our limited minds
to understand an unlimited God for our finite minds
to understand an infinite God.
It is nearly impossible.
Which by the way isn't a bad thing
because then he can be God and we don't have to be.
And it spars, wor, it spurs worship, right?
It sparks it in us.
But it's so hard to understand
that some people have drifted into heresy, into falsehood
as they try to explain it.
Some people say that God takes on different
forms like water.
You go back to physical science and middle school, right?
You got ice and steam and water, right?
So you taking different forms.
The problem is that that's called modalism, which denies
that God is actually three distinct persons,
but one being just takes different forms
as he needs to.
That's false. Or some say that the father, son,
and spirit are each a part of God,
like each of them are a third.
You put them together and it makes up the whole.
That's again, heresy.
It's a falsehood called partialism
that the son is only part God.
Mormons even mistranslate verse one by saying
that the word was a God.
'cause when you go back to the Greek language, that word
for God doesn't have a definite Article V in front of it.
So what they're saying is that this word was divine, yes,
but was not God almighty, that this, this,
the word was created in the beginning
of our world's time in order to rule over this world
one of many worlds.
Again, though the problem is that the actual text
of scripture can't mean any of that
because the whole verse in verse one is all about God
Almighty, even about this word, it's tying it together.
It's all about him. The very phrase itself uses a linking
word that equates both sides.
The word was God, that was equates the two.
There's all over the New Testament cases where yes,
it doesn't have a definite article,
but we don't have to put a in front of it in those cases.
So you see, it doesn't even make sense.
You're trying to make an argument for something
that cannot stand in the text.
And so we can toss that.
But in the end, what do we boil it down to?
In the end, what we learn from this is that God, the Son
is God almighty God,
the Son is the word is God almighty, co-equal
with the Father three in one, not confusing the persons
nor dividing the essence.
That's the truth.
In the beginning was the word, the word was
with God and the word was God.
Again, this is Emmanuel.
Like if we stop and think this is eman, this God
is who came to be with us, the infinite
taking on the finite, the unlimited being,
taking on a body, all of that
for you and for me, like just let
that spark some worship this Christmas season.
I know it's hard. You hear same thing over
and over every year, like just rest in e Emmanuel this year
and let that fill your heart
and fill your soul with worship for
who this God actually is.
And listen, that was just the first two verses
like we're not even done yet.
Look at what verses three
and four say this is even further than what we just saw.
Look at verses three and four.
All things were made through him
and without him was not anything made that was made
in him was life and the life was the light of men.
Now we'll get to that light concept next week,
but you saw it here right in the beginning here
in him was life.
That's the, that's the idea here.
We saw what that in the beginning idea shows us now in him
was life.
That's the point this week in this eternal word in this God,
the son in him
was life.
Now I've got it up here, but one
of my favorite board games growing up was the game of life.
Anybody remember this? Look at that hair by the way, right?
Like this, this is the original.
They've changed the game over the years.
They've modified it. Now you can be
a software developer, right?
But, but I'm talking about this one, this one
where a lawyer makes $50,000, 1982, right?
And you get a, I was looking through the game,
you could catch a lion and get a $4,000 reward.
Like who's gonna do that? Where are you catching a lion?
I don't know. But anyway, like the whole point
of this game back then,
but you still look at the rules today, the whole point
of the game, even today, you, you know how you win.
You end up with the most money. That's it.
Everybody finishes the game,
but whoever has the most money at the end wins the game.
Now you hear that
and we all kind of scoff like at least you're better.
So you look respectable to the people around you, right?
But don't we live our lives like that so often, every day
like that is the goal.
That is the end game.
That is the winning task
because it's not just a board game.
Our culture promotes that as the very way
to win at life.
You've heard it, right? Whoever dies with the most toys
wins wrong.
Whoever dies with the most toys still dies.
It doesn't matter. You have the same fate as everyone else.
It doesn't matter how much money you have,
everyone has the same Listen,
Jesus pierced that so deeply.
Listen to what he says.
Mark 8 36, what does it profit a man
to gain the whole world and yet forfeit his soul?
And we think, okay, well that's people have a lot
of money, greedy people.
That disease is in every single one of us
because you and I are not maybe necessarily searching
for life and money, but we are all searching
for life in so many things.
It could be money, right?
You could be like, well I gotta meet that next milestone.
As soon as I get to that point, then I'm set. We're set.
Right? That that could be where you're finding life
or it could be any number of other things.
You could look for life in your kids.
You could look for life in your status at school
or in your political stances
or in how many followers you have on social media.
'cause what do we mean by life, right?
Let's clear that up for a second. Life is satisfaction.
It's joy, it's fulfillment. Life is pleasure.
It's basically what the Old Testament refers to as shalom,
that idea of peace, that everything is in order.
Everything is as it should be in my life.
And so what we do is we look towards money or sex or sports
or government or promotion to find
that shalom in our lives.
But you know what? They always let you down.
They always let you down.
Go read the whole book of Ecclesiastes in the Old Testament.
This king of Israel named Solomon could
try everything he wanted.
He could look
for life in everything in the world he could
have ever wanted.
But his conclusion at the end of it is
that it's all meaningless.
It's all vanity, it's all chasing after the wind.
Now he doesn't say that those things can't be
used for good good.
He's saying to us, God is saying to us, those things cannot
sustain life.
Doesn't John one paint a very different picture for us?
It says in him was life.
In this word in God the Son was
life meaning don't look anywhere else for it.
It's found in him. The life we long for is found in him.
And here's why that makes sense.
Lemme show you why this all ties together.
'cause look again at verse three. All things
were made through him, through the word
and without him was not anything made that was made.
This is talking about physical life, right?
That in the word comes physical life.
This is where we're starting. He Hebrews one says the same
thing about God the Son.
Listen to Hebrews one verses two and three.
In these last days, he's spoken to us by his son
whom he appointed the heir of all things through whom
also he created the world.
He the God the Son is the radiance of the glory of God,
the exact imprint of his nature,
and he upholds the universe by the word
of his power.
See that God created all things through His
Son, through the word.
Remember how he did it back in Genesis one, remember that
narrative God created?
How did he create and God
said, let there be light.
God said, let there be animals.
He spoke words
through his word.
He created all things. He upholds all things.
Okay, we get that. Why is that so important for this?
Because if he created everything,
if he designed everything to work in a certain way,
then shouldn't we listen to
how he says we should use it all?
If we're looking for life, if we want things
to work the best, shouldn't we listen to the designer
of everything He created you.
He created me. He created nature.
He created marriage. He created money. He created sex.
He created authority.
He created everything, which means he knows how
to best use it all.
So here's, here's why that matters
because we're seeking life here.
We know and learn is that in him is that abundant life
that we're looking for
physical life, the way he created it, designed it to work.
When we look to him
and we follow him in that abundant life is
what comes from it.
Listen to how Jesus said it in John 10, verse 10.
He compares the way of the world, the way of the enemy, the
what it brings in our lives versus the way he designs it.
John 10 10 says, the thief, the enemy comes only
to steal and kill and destroy.
I came the word God the Son came that they may have life
and have it abundantly,
And I want you to hear this.
That abundant life he's talking about has nothing to do with
how wealthy you are
or with how healthy you are
or whether you are married or not
or whatever else you might think of that that could be part
of what it means to be an abundant life.
No, the abundant life the word has for you involves
flourishing according to his design for you.
Where you live out of this overflow of his love,
that you're spilling out joy, that you're peaceful,
that you're patient, that you see things
show up in your life like kindness and goodness
and faithfulness and gentleness.
The self-control pouring outta your life keeps you from
destruction day after day.
That's what we see the abundant life look like.
Where you're growing in your love for God, your love
for others, even your enemies
where no hatred reigns in your heart.
That's the abundant life
where you're seeing relationships flourish
because they're being handled God's way in a pure way
that you can enjoy the good gifts that God's given
to us in the context that he gave them to us
and it's life giving.
It's abundant Where you're
watching your generosity, bless others
as you steward the many resources
or the few resources that God has entrusted to you
and you're watching him use you in those ways where you're
participating in God's ministry to His people
as you're serving others with your time, with your talents,
as you're watching him work through you,
as you're seeing him bless others through you.
That's the abundant life.
See, that is the good life.
Not what the games
and the world will tell you is the good life.
That's the good life in Him was life.
In him is life.
It has nothing to do with any of that other stuff.
It has everything to do with who you're living for.
Like when I see him as my life, as my source,
as my joy, then I'm freed up to that abundant life
to live everything out He's promised me to live.
That's the abundant life. You know where that starts though?
Like we'd love that. We'd long for that.
You know where that starts? It starts by seeing him
as your spiritual life.
First. We want the abundant life.
We're looking for it every
day it starts.
God's design for that starts when you see him
as your spiritual life.
Because we are, hear me, our world doesn't say this.
Nobody agrees with this outside of this room.
It seems like we are dead spiritually on our own.
Every human born of a man
and a woman dead spiritually on our own
and there's nothing we can do about it.
The only way out is for the life, the resurrection
and the life to reach into that dead tomb we are in
and make us alive spiritually
through his merciful and loving life, death
and resurrection in our place.
If you're dead, you can't make yourself alive.
You have to have someone who's alive reach into it
and make you alive.
How do you get that new life?
How do you become spiritually alive?
It is not by works so that no one can boast.
It's only by placing your faith in the free gift of God
for you, his eternal life for you.
You've heard this before. You've seen it on the signs
behind the field, goals at a football game, John three 16,
for God so loved the world that he gave his only son
that whoever believes in him shall not
perish but have eternal life.
John 5 24.
Truly I say to you, whoever hears my word
and believes him who sent me has eternal life.
He does not commit a judgment.
He's passed from death to life.
Remember the story about Easter, right?
Christmas coming up, but Easter matters
to Jesus came out of the grave alive.
He died, but passed from death to life.
That Jesus right there says,
if you believe you have passed from death to life
spiritually alive,
you have eternal life and that eternal life, listen, is yes,
certainly life that lasts forever
with God in the new heavens and new earth.
Yes, praise God that that's coming,
but it's so much more than that too.
Eternal life is
so much more than merely fire insurance for after you die.
It is a new awakening, a new life
inside you that begins when you believe.
Listen to what Jesus said, John 17, verse three.
He said, this is eternal life
that they know you Father, the only true God
and Jesus Christ, whom you have sent.
Do you see that this? Jesus says it. He defines it.
This is eternal life. What does he say it is?
It's not fire insurance. It's not heaven.
Eternal life is a living, breathing,
real relationship with this God of the universe.
He says, that's eternal, that we know,
that we know intimately know the only true
God through the word that he has sent.
Like what? What great grace is it church
that this Emmanuel, this God with us, this glorious,
glorious God, yet near to us, God with us,
that he would come to accomplish all of this so that you
and I could know him and be with him forever.
Is that not just a stunning grace to us?
Do you believe it? Do,
do you believe and see him as your source of life
today and every day and for eternity?
Do you see him as life?
Listen, you will never find true life
until you truly follow Jesus
In Him is life.
Let's bow our heads together just
to reflect on that for a moment.
That idea of God with us,
the word eternal God, the Son
taking on flesh to accomplish everything needed
for our eternal life.
Do you believe that?
Have you seen those facts, those truths,
maybe mentally agreed to that?
Yeah. Okay, and maybe you were even baptized
at some point when you were little,
but you're seeing now you've never
actually said Jesus, I'm in.
I'm all in. I see you as my savior and my Lord I'm in.
Do you believe that's the way the word means? Believe it.
Not just agree to it. Believe it.
I'm not saying you have
to feel it hard enough this Sunday versus last year
or camp this year versus last year.
That's not what I'm saying. It's not a feeling.
It's like, God, I'm in. I don't have any other hope.
Do you believe that?
If you don't, why wait?
Why? If you see it, if you agree with it, say, God, I'm in.
I believe I'm yours.
Just cry out to him in your heart right now.
Admit you're a sinner. Believe that he came to save you
and did all of this, that he is who he says he is.
Confess him as Lord of your life
And tell somebody about it.
But if you do believe this, if this is your hope,
maybe use this next few minutes to reflect on
how we've sought life in so many other things.
Me included every day finding,
looking for joy, peace,
and everything else but him.
God, forgive us for that. Forgive me for that.
That I so flippantly
handle my relationship with the God of the universe who came
to be with us, not just came to be with us.
Live inside of us as your people,
and we just treat it as if it's nothing.
As if everything else is way more important.
God forgive us for that. It is. It's your breath.
You are the very giver of life in our lungs,
and so what else would we do?
But use that to praise you, to use our lives
that you've given to us, to live for you.
God forgive us for selfish living.
May we give our whole hearts to you even today
and see you work in powerful, abundant ways.
Thank you, God.